where do you think like the future of
like storytime animators is going to go
now like what's what's what's like the
what's like the field like right now
because you said it was like not as
not at its peak like it was before i
feel like well
for the most part is i it's a lot of kid
audience yeah um i tried to i've always
from the beginning try to uh
stray away from the the kid friendly
like i'll be like pg maybe pg 13. yeah i
have a rated r yeah
because i don't want to establish myself
as like oh this is for kids and then
they had their mom just angry at me and
stuff yeah yeah yeah yeah i slept like a
penis joke every now and then um
no never because we could spend like a
month on a video and then have it
demonetized because you said [ __ ] once
uh yeah yeah yeah yeah so we don't swear
yeah
i'm too british for that um yeah i'm too
australian yeah yeah but you can you can
like kind of get away with that if
you're like oh this video only took me
like three days to film i can
try to i don't want to throw away work
just so i can't yeah
it's not as bad as like a whole month
though you know
the risk the risk to reward is less you
know
i think my nude model video got like
demonetized but i was like ah fair
enough i drew like a dick and a butt and
another dick in a butt
wait wait so you're you're afraid to say
[ __ ] because you get demonetized but
you're still slipping a penis joke
well you're still drawing dicks
there's there's like cheats you can do
that's right oh dude
what's the hack you don't make you don't
make it too detailed
you don't have no rights
uh you could slip in like maybe one vein
well that's it
and you end the sentence with
but with a 2d animation or or just like
story timers or whatever yeah i think
if you have a team you'll maybe survive
and then most of them are will either
get burnt out or they're just like right
yeah i'm done yeah let me move on like
yeah what do you think is like what do
you think it's like the path that most
story time animators take
because like the path of a lot of
anitubers is the thing yeah i think
that's the tough part um
for most part they honest only wants
art or like 2d yeah yeah yeah so when
they stray away from that path the the
audience loses interest so they're like
i'm not gonna i don't care like whatever
i mean but there's been a couple of
story time animators who have still
found success in like other avenues
right obviously maybe not as like
massive as the peak but you know like
this like you know there's a couple i
can't name off names specifically but
like i think they're trying different
things i think i think with youtube you
always have to try different things you
have to of course yeah change everything
uh i do that sometimes and then like if
i stray too much i'm like okay i'll just
do one video to reset it and then i'll
start a straight again yeah yeah yeah
yeah like if it's like a full like shift
like completely away then that's how
you'll alienate your audience yeah if
it's like a gradual like
fading yeah i think that's the best way
to it's tricky though because since you
only release like a video like once or
twice or three times
yeah like you can only
slowly sway them like it would take too
long or take like a year by the time
you're like done yeah slow
progression did you have like one video
that like blew up or did like crazy
numbers yeah so oh yeah so yeah when i
was in my basement dying and jobless and
my mom was like go get a job go get a
job and i was like i'm trying i'm trying
uh
actually i was about to quit uh on on
the video
uh
which was called uh nude models actually
yeah nude models that one's on that one
that wasn't one that blew up i was about
to quit and i i told everybody my family
members and everybody because i was
feeling like [ __ ] i was depressed um and
everybody else was like if they
mentioned the word job near me i would
freak out
but yeah basically uh
uh my friend posted a
uh on our slash video
my nude model video yeah and it got the
most upvotes oh and then like it blew up
so then i went i made another video and
then it snowballed and it and then
that's how i'm here today oh okay
basically what was the thing that you
told your friends and family about like
if the video failed what would you what
did you tell them oh well at the time it
was
it was always low views because i had
like what like 70 subs from so
he gave me like 700 subs but that's not
enough to like yeah yeah yeah
like if i don't get 100k views including
i was there yeah basically what was the
oh because if you do it long enough
you're like i can't do this anymore like
i
i have to get a real job because it's
already been like almost two years so
what were your views getting what kind
of numbers were you pulling in before
that and then that video oh like
million two million three million that's
what
i think it's like
three million five million i don't
[ __ ] before that you were getting
like what like ten thousand thousand
oh i was getting like like a hundred wow
wow yeah so i went from like a hundred
hundred views
i actually i went from like like 70 700
subscribers because of joey and then i i
jumped up all the way straight to 400k
and then only people on twitter were
like or like
like
like in my dms and i was like scared
because i'm like they're gonna use me or
they're gonna use me yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah i closed myself off because i'm
like i'm like no no no no stay away stay
away because
the story time community where um
they it was built off collabing a lot
yeah yeah yeah yeah i felt like i only
want to collab when i like i really know
the post yeah no other person yeah
yeah but like but when you're starting
off with collabing right off the bat
like you know like that's what they want
in their mind yeah it puts me off i'm
waiting
yeah because like i've never had the
experience like just blowing up
overnight like hey i mean it's cool it's
awesome yeah yeah yeah
every motion you're seeing actually
a lot more cynical back then but now i'm
just i'm chilling yeah yeah
political household you're like they're
all gonna leave me they don't want to
watch no it's cynical as in like are you
using me yeah oh oh what other youtubers
yeah yeah yeah
well i felt bad though because i i i
like you know some people hit me up yeah
yeah i push them away i'm like oh but
he's like i learned later like a year or
two later i'm like
you know that's pretty cool [ __ ] i
ruined that yeah but like i don't think
i don't think it's bad to be cautious
because especially like after you blow
up overnight and suddenly everyone's in
your dms and like well you guys weren't
talking to me before and now like
everyone's up in my dms yes you know and
like that's that's why i like i
i rarely ever it's like the people you
know who like are on tv you know like 30
seconds and then they're like third
cousin yeah yeah yeah it's like hey yeah
yeah yeah exactly it's sauce yeah yeah
yeah yeah exactly
yeah and then like especially in the
youtube community there are definitely
cool guys and cool girls out there but
there are some but there are
[Music]
but there are definitely some that are
definitely just like not and therefore
they are there for the class
like i have to meet them in person oh
yeah of course yeah i mean that helps an
awful lot yeah yeah i always find a lot
of the internet [ __ ] drops i know
when you meet someone yeah yeah that was
you was a black butler you were in the
black butler at the time what was your
black butlering